si x existe en los números naturales
unión el 0 a menos que pierda directo x
existe en estos números de aquí es decir
que x x existe para eso utilizamos a
esta en a esta especial significa existe
en o pertenece a los números naturales
unión del 0 es decir a los números 0
porque tenemos el 0 unión el 0 0 1 2 3 4
y así todos los demás
ok espera qué feo símbolo ok perfecto y
después nos dicen a qué otra clase de
conjuntos de números pertenece x o qué
nos referimos a x y se me olvidó por
aquí ponerlo a pertenece
ok muy bien ahora fíjate que si es que
se existe aquí entonces vamos a fijarnos
en todos los demás números ahora estos
números naturales unión el 0
especificamos que si está el 0 porque
hay algunas personas que dicen que el 0
está contenido en las naturales y otras
personas que dicen que el 0 no está
contenido en los naturales así que no
nos quitemos de problemas y mejor vamos
a ver a los números naturales sin contar
el 0 y en este caso ya le unimos el 0 ya
le pegamos el 0 a ver x existen los
números naturales los números naturales
naturales y bueno es que podemos ver o
podemos pensar a los números naturales
como dos enteros positivos enteros
enteros positivos por sí
y esto recuérdalo porque habíamos dicho
que los números enteros eran todos los
números naturales es decir todos los
enteros que son positivos el 0 y también
todas las versiones de los números
naturales en negativo por lo tanto si yo
me fijo en los naturales los naturales
son los números 1 2 3 4 y todos los
demás ahora si yo quiero preguntarme o
espera si yo quiero preguntarme si x
existe aquí bueno pues date cuenta que x
puede existir en cualquiera de estos
pero también puede ser 0 y si x puede
ser 0 entonces no forzosamente existe
aquí existe una posibilidad de que x
valga 0 y por lo tanto no podríamos
asegurar que está aquí entonces x no
podemos asegurar que están los naturales
ok ahora si pensamos en los enteros si
pensamos en los enteros o que los
números enteros son todos los números
que se ven como puntitos menos tres coma
menos 2 menos 10 123 y todos los demás
ahora quiero que te des cuenta que en
esta ocasión si podemos asegurar que x
está aquí y podemos asegurar que está
aquí porque fíjate que aquí estamos
conteniendo a todos los números de los
cuales puede tomar un valor x estamos
contando a todos estos números 0 1 2 3 4
y todos los demás por lo tanto aquí sí
puedo asegurar que x está en los enteros
x está en los enteros ok y déjame
ponerlo así x entonces existe en los
enteros es decir en los enteros muy bien
estará x en los racionales
bueno pues también podemos decir de una
manera muy fácil que x si existe en los
nacionales porque recuerda que los
enteros están incluidos los racionales
los racionales son los números que se
pueden ver de la forma en me entrené en
mente en donde m y n son enteros pero
todos los números naturales unión en
cero toda esta parte de aquí los podemos
ver como un número racional porque
siempre los podemos dividir entre uno ok
x si están los racionales x estarán los
irracionales pues de una manera muy
rápida podemos concluir que no no está
en los racionales porque están los
racionales si están los racionales no
están los profesionales recuerdan y
podemos también concluir que x está en
los números reales y también lo puedo
concluir una manera muy rápida porque si
están los racionales está en los reales
recuerda que los reales habíamos dicho
que eran los racionales unión los
irracionales por lo tanto está en los
reales y ya hemos acabado